d'habitude ils sont trois
exceptionnellement pour l'agenda Florent
et Jean nous ont ouvert la tour
séraphique
balladonirik pop psychédélique trans
voire même bidouillage
c'est vraiment ce côté un peu même
brocante quand on s'installe sur scène
il y a tout intérêts d'instruments c'est
comme voilà ça c'est bricoler on rajoute
des choses on essaie plein de choses en
expérimente quand on rencontre une
violence et liste faire du violoncelle
voilà et c'est comme ça qu'on pour ça
même c'est raffine le nom ça définit pas
grand chose parce que c'est toujours on
avance toujours et la définition
franchement on sera un peu à la fin
une approche empirique de la musique
l'autre a suivi les cours de l'école
Didier Lockwood
il voyage
elles influencent c'est vraiment
l'argent ça peut être de la musique
traditionnelle mongole africaine
malienne ça peut être musique répétitive
américaine
les gros groupes quoi le monde qu'on
propose est assez onirique donc on a
envie d'aller vers ça voilà donc on
commence tout juste on a envie d'aller
vers de la scénographie vers la vidéo
les projections vers un spectacle un peu
plus global quoi plus totale
sur scène les yeux les oreilles sont
mobilisés le prochain spectacle sera
sans doute digne des Floyd à Pompéi
c'est des enfants qui sont trop souvent
incompris de par leur trou du
comportement de par le fait qu'on a
aucun échange verbal alors mais tu peux
te mordre ça changera rien du coup on se
comprend comment par le toucher par un
regard par la confiance
moi je reste persuadée aujourd'hui que
ces enfants ont besoin de beaucoup de
choses pas que du soin pas que de
l'école
ils ont besoin d'aller dehors et qu'on
les aide à se socialiser vers
l'extérieur
mardi soir
boggers au festival festyol à
Meung-sur-Loire ce sera vendredi
prochain
des variations de sculpture ici
construction architecture sans chevêtre
Sébastien Zener et pierrefeller exposent
leurs pièges à Argenton-sur-Creuse